hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreign again today we're
gonna be doing something a little bit
different so the testing grounds came
out with another update and there's
gonna be even more damage changes so the
big video that I made on the damage
changes still kind of applies but now
there's going to be even more changes to
some of the characters some of them
didn't get any changes like T on D for
example but other characters like warden
and Conqueror they also got some changes
so we're gonna be going over what those
are it within this video so as long as
like the V if you do enjoy subscribe if
you knew I covered the informational
site a foreigner that being the balance
changes the here updates the patch notes
in the leaks if you want to be kept up
to date with everything happening into
the world or foreigner and never miss
out on an update that face day subscribe
the channel
and with that let's get started with
today's damage values video also just
one thing really quickly you are going
to be noticing that I'm playing breach
and yet it's on the testing ground this
was footage from the last testing ground
when we did the breach stuff changes
which is why you're gonna be seeing a
lot of different weird things happening
I couldn't get footage for today's video
foreigner servers were [ __ ] me today
and I kept like getting disconnected so
that's what we're gonna have to deal
with I just want to preface just in case
if you were confused
so first up for the nights we have
warden and his crushing counter-strike
it now deals 18 damage in the live which
is what you're going to be seeing in
that number it was 25 so in the live
server I believe it's 40 in the test
server it's 25 and now that 25 has been
changed to 18 so that's where they're
getting that down from up from number so
even less damage now I don't actually
know what the full punishes I believe
it's now 30 because the 18 for the
crushing counter-strike 12 for the
follow up light that's guaranteed so
technically 30 but I feel like that's
just a little bit low for certain warden
players reconquer he got a buff his
opener top heavy that used to do 14
damage down deals 24 and his flail
uppercut which is that full block
uppercut unblockable that used to do 16
now does 24 damage her peacekeeper the
opener top heavy now deals 21 damage
down from 26 opener left and right
heavies now deal 19 down from 24
finisher heavies now deal 24 down from
29 dashing thrust is 13 as opposed to 18
and sidestep is now 13 down from 19 so
lots of nerves to peacekeeper for long
the top light attack is now 500 up from
400 and paling charge now deals five
damage as opposed to eight blind justice
is 24 damage down from 39 blind justice
also deals now 40 stamina damage
light applause now deals 15 stamina
damage and for the top heavy second
top-heavy and finisher top heavy in the
chain it is now 30 stamina 35 stamina
and 40 stamina damaged respectively for
gladiator DS zone attack and now deals
15 damage this is down from 27 huge nerf
to him but I think it was definitely
well worth it and as well as the skewer
doing now to damages supposed to 20 and
this I have to clarify for the further
rest of the video this 2 damage means
the light attack not the bleed attack so
when we originally did ski were in the
testing ground it was 20 damage from the
attack and then the 30 or so bleed that
came from it thus making it like a 55
damage punish now it's just doing that
to light attack damage and then the
bleed following it so it's gonna be
doing less but the bleed is still the
same this goes for a majority of the
cast coming up further in the video as
for the zone attack I think it was well
worth it it what doesn't really make a
whole lot of sense to me was that the
zone attack and the dashing light had
the same exact damage and were the
optimal punish for a heavy parry but yet
the zone got buffed and the top light
got nerfed I thought it would if
anything would be the opposite and then
lastly for the Knights is black prior
and then the bulwark counter now deals
24 damage down from 30 I'm pretty sure
this means the flip I'm pretty sure that
is the actual pronunciation for the move
the bulwark counter but either way this
now deals 24 damage down from 30 going
over to Raider we now have the Vikings
Raiders fury now those 34 damage this is
opposed to 44 so the zone attack I
believe is getting a nerf for warlord be
blocked and stabbed now deals 13 damage
this is down from 17 boredom blade is 24
damage up from 18 and the guaranteed
light attack after a headbutt is now 13
damage down from 17 so that light attack
specifically is getting a nerf for
Berserker his left heavy finisher now
deals 33 damage this is down from 45 for
Valkyrie hearse Pierce
we punished now deals 21 damage down
from 35 and these side light finishers
now deal ad stamina damage I'm pretty
sure that's a buff because ad stamina is
a lot of stamina for Highlander his
defensive stance opener light now
properly change into the second light
and Celtic curse now deals 24 damage up
from 23 on the left and 21 on right
sides so the defensive stamina opener
what are the defensive stance opener was
actually I had a lot of trouble with
that during the testing of the testing
girls and I made that giant half an hour
video for some odd reason I couldn't
chain it to the second light I tried
forever I thought I was bugged or
something like that so I'm glad that
this is fixed properly all you
Highlander mains that were very confused
now we understand the reason why for
shaman Ravens bio now deals one damage
down from 15 Raven's claw is also one
damaged out from 15 Ravens beak is 15
down from 20 and predators mercy is 40
down from 50 now predators mercy is the
bite attack I don't have a problem with
this with this specific move having 10
less damage because obviously you have
to take into account 9 times out of 10
you're gonna be using this in a 4v4
setting with teammates next to you so
that extra damage they're gonna be doing
is gonna be phenomenal damage against
the opponent and of course you're
getting your stamina back and you're
healing yourself so I think the 40
damage is completely fine with me Ravens
bile and ravens clawed now deals 1
damage like I stated but that's going to
be the light attack damage this is not
going to be the actual bleed attack good
because in the testing ground it did 15
damage plus the 16 bleed now it just
does the 1 damage plus the 16 boots so
the bleed isn't going anywhere it's just
the light attack or the heavy attack
beforehand the bleed is staying the same
the damage was a bit rough it's just
like gladiator skewer though and then to
finish off the Vikings we have Yahoo's
hammer slam is now dealing 40 down from
50 sandwich shamans bite force ago key
the mid charge opener heavy now deals 24
damage this was down from 26 and the
uncharged heavy finishers now till 29
up from 19 so good damage buffs there
for hurricane blast and now deals 46
damage for a roach II but this used to
be up from 35 so even more damage really
really nice I believe hurricane blast is
the heavy deflect so that's well worth
it same thing goes for no Bushido poke
the nest
light finisher is now one damaged down
from six Vipers retreat is four damage
down from fourteen and Cobra strike is
four damage down from thirteen I have to
preface like I said before this is the
light attack damage before the actual
bleed starts to kick in the bleed is not
changing and then the finisher left left
heavy now deals twenty six damage this
is down from thirty-five coming down to
the last four people we have shinobi
ranged open our heavies now deal twenty
five down from twenty eight the left
heavy finisher now deals thirty down
from thirty-five and shadow strike which
i think is that light attack after you
deflecting out deals thirteen down from
sixteen I could be wrong on that though
ARA Musha ring the bell now deals twelve
damage this was up from zero because I'm
pretty sure ring the bell did no damage
in the testing ground and then the
deadly faint sides now do eleven damage
down from twenty four new show she has a
small change in sandwich Shaolin douches
echo striking out deals thirty seven
damage up from 29 and Shaolin Sun kick
strike and now deal sixteen down from
twenty just judging from the comments it
seems like a lot of people are
definitely noticing that the skewer
damage doing at twenty was pretty
[ __ ] ridiculous and now it doing two
seems pretty nice cuz the bleed is still
the same the bleed is still the same the
damage beforehand is really really
nerfed but I think it's totally
understanding why that gets totally fine
and obviously I must preface that if you
do not like these changes remembered
that this is what the testing ground is
for that's why there's going to be a
survey on this write a post and I'll
actually link the survey in this video
here because I forgot to do it in last
week's video because they didn't show it
but I will link the survey down in the
description if you want to fill it out
or if you want to fill it out again I
don't think you could fill out up again
but if you can definitely now with the
importance of these new damage values
getting changed but if you Det if you
didn't fill it out the first time I
become a I'm commanding you this I'm not
even telling you to like just I'm not
even recommending you I'm demanding that
you sign it because it's this is what's
gonna happen the the game is going to
change drastically if these changes come
in so we have to make sure that these
changes are up to our liking overall
though this patch wasn't too bad in
terms of what they're adding to testing
ground I do have to kind of ask what's
going on with wardens crush encounter I
feel like there's a real big reason why
they're adding less damage to this thing
so I don't really understand why though
because crush encounter doing 18 damage
is pretty yikes I was okay with 25 but
18 seems a little bit low obviously I've
taken to account the light attack that's
guaranteed thus making it I think like a
30 damage punish but still you could
just do like a random heavy attack but
also that could easily be parried maybe
there's a reason for it that we don't
know yet we'll have to wait and see
though and then I know obviously the
bleed attacks are gonna get some hate
especially some no bushi players but
like I said the regular light attack
damage is getting nerfed the bleed seems
to be staying the same which is
fantastic because Nobu she needs that
bleed yeah guys that's gonna be the end
of the bait say hopefully you guys did
enjoy it licked it but if he did
subscribe for a new I cover the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes to hear
updates the passwords and the leaks if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update definitely stay subscribe the
channel that guys take her over girls
today I'll see you for tomorrow's video
and peace out
you